fantastic
excellent
so moving on in our on our program
we wanted uh to highlight environmental
health uh disparities and environmental
justice issues that are facing um our
nation and our region and also in those
local settings
and uh to facilitate and moderate our
our next session which is a panel of
wonderful speakers
dr danielle stevens-watkins is going to
be the moderator so i'll introduce her
and then turn it over to her in the
esteems panel
uh dr stephen watkins is a she received
a phd in counseling psychology from the
university of kentucky she also has her
master's in clinical psych
from spalding university
she is now the assistant vice president
for research and diversity and inclusion
here at uk and she leaves our unite
research priority area she has been
funded by nih for decades
and has research focusing on health
disparities and barriers to service and
utilization among african-american
populations
so danielle we are very glad to have you
as part of this event um
and the the panel of yours
[Music]
good afternoon everyone thank you so
much for joining us
i have the pleasure to introduce our
three panelists
for this afternoon panel session
i will start with our first panelist
heather henry heather henry is a program
officer with the superfund research
program at the national institute of
environmental health science
located in the research triangle park in
north carolina
at nieh heather manages
research grant programs
including university grants and small
business grants with topics ranging from
toxicology environmental cleanups
community engagement
covet 19
and disaster response research
heather is a member of the niehs
environmental health disparities and
environmental justice faculty and is
involved in several efforts to promote
diversity equity and inclusion at niehs
we are so fortunate to have heather this
afternoon
thank you and i want to introduce
heather
thank you danielle and thank you so much
erin for the invitation to
talk here today
and very much enjoyed the prior
presentation by dr frumpkin
i'm going to be talking about the
national perspective or a national
perspective regarding environmental
health disparities
and
i'm going to be taking an attack talking
about research legislation as well as
coordination
so i thought i'd start out with some
definitions
a health disparity is a health
difference closely linked to social
economic
and or environmental disadvantages so
when it comes to an environmental health
disparity
these are stress these are disparities
related from
resulting from stressors including
environmental exposures
exposures that might be related to
natural or man-made disasters
and these disparities amplify or
increase existing health disparities in
vulnerable communities
and by vulnerable communities
we tend to notice that these are
communities experiencing lower ses
closer to pollution limited health care
may be experiencing a lifetime burden of
multiple exposures as well as limited
literacy
environmental justice goes alongside
with environmental health disparity and
is sort of an aspirational goal to
achieve a fair treatment and meaningful
involvement of people regardless of race
color national origin or income with
respect to the development
implementation and enforcement of
environmental laws regulation and
policies
i think it's important to note
that the when it comes to environmental
health disparities a majority falls on
low-income minority tribal and
indigenous communities they're more
likely to be
bearing the hazard the environmental
insults that are involved with
environmental health disparities
so i'm going to start
by giving a context of what's happening
at niehs
we're not the only institute from the
national institutes of health that is
working on environmental health
disparities
but certainly we um the work that is
being done at niehs is illustrative of
other efforts
and it's a very important um aspect of
our own strategic plan to uncover and
understand
um these social determinants of health
as well as promote environmental justice
so start with
research that's happening at niehs um
those of you may know we're located in
national we're located in research
triangle park north carolina
and we have several scientists
working
working there
in laboratories and running contracts
as it pertains to environmental health
disparities
the national toxicology program
does several toxicity testing related to
chemicals that might be associated with
ethnic personal care products
diseases that are more common among
minorities or pesticides and migrant
workers we have an active epidemiology
group
working in several communities
looking at environmental justice issues
and we also sponsor community forums
with
with our director rick wojcik
and then have coordination efforts for
groups that relate to environmental
health disparities such as disaster
research as well as environmental
global health
and niehs is also involved with covid
activities that are at the nih level
and as it relates to
environmental health disparities there
are two programs that work directly with
underserved populations
niehs has a management role for some of
those
radix up is a testing strategy for
underserved populations and radix rad is
a water wastewater surveillance
means to assess coded in communities
but i'm going to turn gears now and talk
more about the work that niehs is
funding
and we have a program
for environmental health disparities
that look at basic and epidemiological
as well as social scientific factors
that explain uh the burden of disease in
lower socioeconomic populations
uh partnerships for environmental public
health
has a research to action program this is
this highlights
the importance of community engaged
research
the worker training program provides
work skills to impacted communities
the superfund research program is an
example of the multi-disciplinary
research that dr trumpkin was talking
about and
has a systems approach to problem
solving
and then lastly we have a time-sensitive
research grant program which enables
small groups small grants encouraging
partnerships between researchers and
disaster affected communities many of
whom are some of the vulnerable
communities that i was mentioning
previously
so just to give an example of one of the
environmental health disparities
research centers
this feature is on madras which is a
maternal
maternal development risk from
environmental and social stressors the
center is out of the university of
southern california and focuses in on
low-income hispanic women in los angeles
area
and i just want to point out some recent
work that they've done
mapping coded case rate pollution and
public transit and housing density
and uh
just to make one little take-home
message here that um this this type of
work this type of interaction with
communities has really enabled um
the community outreach uh to let to let
the madras families know more about
kovid's susceptibility
and uh the research to action again this
is a program that really focuses in on
community partnerships and i'm
mentioning just two of them here they're
both relevant to kentucky
the mountain air project focuses on
disparities in appalachian communities
with regard to respiratory health and a
recent program
is one looking at diverse is looking at
disinfection byproducts also in the
appalachian area
and
again in terms of another take-home
message just how important it is
to engage communities in research
especially the type of research that
niehs is doing
not only does this help build capacity
but you know it there is evidence that
it improves
intervention success
uh and i want to point out that the
partnerships in environmental public
health also has a vibrant podcast system
and they had a recent feature on another
kentucky example this is out of
louisville the green heart study
looks to examine the impacts of green
neighborhoods on heart health
and
this type of
intervention i think also points to
another take-home message it's just
sustainable solutions so this this work
is based on rigorous science uh the
solution itself really gives back to the
community through creating additional
green space
and talking about giving back to the
community the worker education and
training program has had a long-standing
interaction of which in training
low-income minority communities who are
in impact who are in communities that
are impacted by hazardous substances so
through
providing job training it has really
raised the capacity not only of
individuals but also their families by
giving them additional livelihoods
the
recent work that has uh has been
undertaken by the worker training
program is to fund specifically um
covid19
uh essential worker training
and so
just to again make another take-home
message about job training and how this
activity not only advances cleanup but
also improves the livelihood of
individuals and families
and
the superfund research program this is
the program
for which i i am a part and
as mentioned before this is a highly
multi-disciplinary research programs it
has biomedical environmental engineering
research a research translation
community engagement
a very important cross-sectoral training
so
training the next generation to to know
how to um converse with
many different sectors
and then data transparency and
integration is also an important part
of these centers
so
a lot going on in these centers and
maybe a point i just wanted to make
relevant to environmental health
disparities and environmental justice
is something that the srp is moving
towards as part of our new strategic
plan um that's a systems approach and
a systems approach at its best um means
inviting multiple perspectives to the
table to understand a full system in
which a problem exists
allowing you to to possibly find um many
solutions um in in multiple sectors
and
um
you know
taking the point home just a little bit
more
you know being a part of the national
institute of health of course we're very
interested in health disparities and
biomedical issues and dysfunctions um
and in some cases uh solutions are found
through biomedical interventions
such as pharmaceuticals but you know in
many cases um you know we're finding
that the
it's not always a biomedical solution
there may be several non-biomedical
solutions
and um i don't think the superfund
research program is the only one doing
this i think the
groups that i've talked about prior to
this are also established showing how
sustainable solutions are can be really
broad for improving health
again having interventions that are
based on science identifying multiple
ways to reduce exposures um that allows
you to tailor
interventions to the community make sure
that it is uh it is in keeping with
economic and
other other practical concerns
um and as as mentioned in the prior
presentation um you can you can address
one problem by
bringing bringing a solution to other
problems so you can give back to the
community and in some cases address
other issues of inequity
uh just briefly wanted to touch on some
uh
ongoing work within the centers
um and make the point about how
important it is to communicate risk and
make informed decision
um
you know
there there's work at the university of
kentucky on diet and health
northeastern university is working with
population puerto rico about risk
uncertainty
for several contaminants that are found
in in the study population
water testing water treatment and
healthy fishing are also
a ways that our grantees are bringing
science and helping
individuals make personal choices to
reduce exposures
and then uh stepping onto a larger scale
uh communities making informed decisions
um having communities at the table for
remediation decisions is very important
and the role of our university centers
to help broker an understanding of the
implications of some remediation efforts
such as pfas incineration and dredging
this is really important to communities
to feel confident that
the solution is not causing additional
problems to their to their uh community
and
uh with climate and extreme weather
events uh there there's also tremendous
opportunity
to understand and try to
suggest
better urban planning
to prevent some of the
vulnerabilities of communities who are
who are impacted by extreme weather
events
that's a good segue to talking about
other national efforts on the horizon uh
being that climate change the executive
order recently
released has several provisions for
environmental justice
so justice 40 is an initiative
originating from a grassroots effort but
now as a part of the executive order
that calls for an investment of 40
percent of federal
activities for climate change to go to
disadvantaged communities
in addition
they'll be ramping up
screening mapping screening tools to
make it
easier to identify vulnerable
communities in a climate and
environmental justice perspective
and uh the executive or order also calls
for the establishment of a white house
environmental justice advisory committee
their next meeting is april 28th
so might be interesting for those who
attend of course it's virtual and
you're able to participate that way
and also the covid stimulus package
included 100 million in funding for
environmental justice grants as well as
a
grant to state and local governments to
reduce air pollution in marginalized
communities
i just want to talk about uh the
department of health and human services
a couple of other activities the atsdr
just released a community stress
resource center and this is a tool for
helping communities understand how they
can reduce stress and build resilience
especially as it relates to
environmental contamination
and um also want to mention healthy
people 2020 this is an excellent
resource for understanding health
disparities uh through time
it pulls together resources from several
databases so you can actually see and
measure how
ethnicity and several other
socioeconomic factors impact
a disease outcome
and related to that is healthy people
2030 which sets goals for the future for
reducing health disparities and among
those
goals are several that relate directly
to environmental health disparities
here's an example of
homes with safe water
lots going on in the federal level and
so coordination is very important and
the interagency working group on
environmental justice is is that group
that helps pull together and coordinate
activities that are happening
great resource for funding opportunities
and events related to environmental
justice and more recently they held a
series of town halls on covet and
natural disasters and underserved
communities and i believe the report is
due out
in august
epa has several environmental justice
resources uh they they award grants they
have a screening tool uh that i
mentioned previously it's gonna be a
part of the climate change package
and then they also have reports on uh
successes in ej communities
and uh finally the
national environmental justice advisory
council is a is a group that informs the
epa and it's coordinated by them and
they also have public meetings
so that was a real whirlwind of national
activities uh
national institute of environmental
health sciences i think given it gives
an idea of the type of work that is
ongoing
in the federal government
basic to applied data-driven research
community-based interventions building
capacity creating value within a
community and taking a systems approach
to solving problems
the white house initiatives as well as
accompanying legislation i think is an
indication that we'll be seeing
more and more of an emphasis on
environmental health disparities and
environmental justice
and with that this builds on several uh
excellent resources and uh products out
of the department of health and human
services as well as the environmental
protection agency um and then again just
to point back to that kind of
overarching idea that you know
we we can look towards uh sustainable
solutions to really improve the health
in vulnerable communities
not only based on understanding of
exposures but helping people under make
good personal choices helping
communities make good decisions about
remediation and urban planning and then
also be ready for um
those surprise events that come up that
we don't expect like code vid19 and
other climate change issues
and so with that
i want to point to you towards a
request for information that is out and
due tomorrow for the niehs inviting
comments and suggestions to advance and
strengthen racial equity diversity and
inclusion in the biomedical research
workforce and advanced health
disparities and health equity research i
also have posted on the this webinar
format a document that has a list of
funding opportunities and other
resources
some of which are listed here
and so i'd like to thank you as an
audience thank the organizers and a big
thanks to the real environmental health
disparity and environmental justice
experts at niehs who provided some help
to me
in putting this live together so thank
you back to you danielle
thank you so much heather for presenting
if you all could
keep your questions to the end and we're
going to present those questions to our
panelists at the end of our last
presentation so please make sure you
document your questions in the q and a
box and i will be revisiting that box at
the end of our panel
our second presenter
is amanda lefevre she is the deputy
commissioner of the department for
environmental protection
amanda serves as the
deputy commissioner and she previously
served as the director of the division
of compliance assistance
dca
she specializes in enhancing the
educational offerings in dca and its
programs which includes compliance
assistance
brownfields and the state environmental
leadership program kyxl
she serves as the chair of the
association of the state and territorial
solid waste management officials
brownfield focus group and the vice
chair of the
cercla
and brownsville subcommittee
amanda earned a bachelor's degree from
brexit university and a master's degree
in public administration from the
university of kentucky
amanda is a kentucky native originally
from falls rough kentucky
welcome amanda thank you
thank you so much and uh thank you for
having me here today uh with some such
wonderful speakers um i'm honored and um
i just want to talk to you a little bit
today about uh our work with
environmental justice within the energy
and environment cabinet
and how we're trying to advance
environmental justice and community
engagement in order to you know help
address those
disparities health
education and economic disparities that
we have in our communities so um and my
cat decided to take a you know make an
appearance today so apologies
um but
the thing about um ej is it's been a
part of my career within department for
environmental protection
since day one
i've been with the with the brownfields
program most of my career and if you're
familiar with brownfields that is
basically
working with communities to uh assess
and remediate
uh properties that are
uh contaminated or thought to be
contaminated so it's your urban blight
it's uh your your rural areas where
factories have gone out it's anything
from dry cleaners to
mines guard lands to
you know
old factories and everything in between
so
i've spent my
career
with environmental justice because it
goes hand in hand uh with
um
brownfields and what we do because we
work directly with communities to
redevelop these properties and get them
back into reuse and that could be
anything from um an urban garden to a
new business that might provide jobs to
social engagement opportunities so um it
can be whatever that community wants and
those are the best redevelopments is
when you can work directly with
community and it's you know a community
decision of what that redevelopment is
so like i said i i've seen it all i've
worked in urban settings and rural
settings
i've seen um
environmental justice uh you know in
terms of income and race um i i've
worked with coal communities with the
ends and flows of that industry uh as
well as other industries and you know if
you go to uh west side of louisville you
know you could see everything from uh
chemical factories to
everything else so um you know it's it's
a little bit of everything but the
impacts are are universal these are the
communities that have um issues with
safe and reliable work uh drinking water
a la martin county which we're working
with really closely right now uh places
have issues with access to food uh you
know
the local convenience store uh should
not be your your main uh source of food
when you get healthy fruits and
vegetables are are really uh what keeps
you healthy not only you know weight
wise but you know
cancer risks and everything like that
you may not have access to health care
uh in these communities and and of
course there's fewer opportunities for
jobs so you can either you know move
move up move out or you know stay in
your neighborhood and you know advance
it so there's certainly challenges um
and so environmental justice is near and
dear to my heart and um
uh you know with my particular job at
dep it's very part and partial to it and
um you know so
i've seen a little bit of everything but
i will tell you the one thing that
really
was an aha moment for me and i think
part of our challenge uh in dep when
we're talking about a new environmental
justice framework which i'll get to here
in a minute is giving all of our
employees that aha moment that really
brings it home to them but early in my
career
um i was in the west end of louisville
at a community uh health and safety fair
and uh there was a mascot there he's
really really brightly colored i've
never seen him before you know i grew up
with louis the lightning bug and um um
you know
things like that but i never seen him
before i went over to the booth and he
was
wally the shelter in place turtle and he
teaches kids about sheltering in place
uh when there's some sort of
environmental um
emergency chemical spill something like
that
and um apparently he's he's originated
in a lot of the
the bands where there are all the
chemical industries in the south but
it was that moment where you know even
though i've grown up um you know
somewhere between middle class and poor
and we had you know
issues with you know bills and stuff
like that um i had never really had to
think about
that part of safety for me you know
what what is it like growing up where
that is necessary where you have to have
a mascot to teach you
about sheltering in place um so that was
a weird little aha moment and it's
really stuck with me so uh but what we
really need is that for our other
cabinet employees because we have people
who um you know do permit applications
well that's mostly calculations and
things like that that may not be out in
about the public but
we want all of our employees to really
understand that everything that we do
with cabinet has some sort of
environmental health impact to someone
somewhere so um
we are undergoing uh a process where we
are
trying to really ramp up our
environmental justice efforts and how we
do business here within the within the
cabinet
so you know just a little background of
course you know
environmental justice is born of the
civil rights
movement specifically there's some key
events uh the memphis sanitation strike
and the warren county pcb landfill that
really sort of kicked off the
environmental justice movement um and
you know that gave way to uh executive
order in 1994 under the clinton
administration that really um made you
know um
may be fair treatment and medical
involvement of all people regardless of
race color national origin or income
you know part of the you know federal
landscape it's that environmental
justice um um you know goal there so
um
and as
um you know as they've had to implement
it of course it applies to all the
federal programs
um
we are a designated
state you know we we
enforce these uh federal programs so the
clean air act safe drinking water act
uh rickra
all of that
we inherit from the federal agencies so
uh we
automatically
you have to you know implement and
internalize those environmental justice
uh frameworks and we have i mean we do
uh
um
open meetings and uh we do uh you know
uh public notification for permit
applications and things like that but
there's also that um you know
want to do more uh and i think
um
um
that you know the bashir administration
came in and i think one of the first few
things uh over the last summer um
um is we realized that we needed to
um look at that our environmental
justice framework and what we're doing
and uh we proposed a new one
so um this is something that we're
currently rolling out we actually just
started it but it's an effort to really
uh make our efforts more fruitful and be
more engaging with the public and with
our communities
when it comes to
environmental decision making
so what we really want to do is raise
awareness of ej with an eec
some of those aha moments like i was
talking about
we want to really um work on effective
community engagement involvement uh and
not just passive notification um and and
really work at communicating information
better to folks
um
there's a lot of agency program
evaluation that we need to do and
integration of ej into different
decision points and of course training
internally and externally and also using
some of the resources that were
mentioned in the last presentation um so
um you know there's there's lots of good
things out there for us to use and for
us to communicate with and for us to
decision make with so it's it's it's
really sort of internalizing all of that
stuff and making it part of our everyday
business
practices
um so
the first thing i want to talk about is
a little bit is community engagement um
and
you know we as a regulatory agency um
we follow the letter of the law so
there's certain things we can and can't
do
but we do know that we can build
relationships with ej communities
so some of the things that we can't do
you know we can work with our partners
so we really want to work on
building relationships with those
organizations that are grassroots
that that really impact
you know communities at the ground level
we want to provide training and
educational materials to people
if
you've ever read an environmental permit
they're not so easy to read
um you know or you know sometimes
you know we have very very technical
documents so you know working on
materials so we meet people where they
are
and meet the needs of the the audience
they're intended to inform
we're going to be looking at open
communication
public notification and involvement
really doing effective public meetings
and hearings once again meeting people
where they are and their needs
and adapt our methods of communication
to community needs
special populations
uh whether that is a hispanic community
or uh you know a
large bosnian community uh what what
type of language needs are there when we
communicate uh to two different audience
so so really just um
um looking at all of those things um
you know in terms of engagement
um
we also want to look at program
integration so
um
program assessment um
i you know looking at everything that we
do uh looking at our decision points
where can we really integrate uh uh
environmental justice as we go through
uh how do we implement that and you know
we have permitting programs we have
those corrective actions programs i
think dr dr henry
mentioned you know having people at the
table when we make remediation decisions
um of course brownfields
regulation development uh funding and
grants do we need a brownfield criteria
criteria uh in in our funding um
applications uh as a decision-making
tool and planning uh and i will say you
know and even in our inter our proactive
uh programs uh after this i'll be
talking about kentucky excel which is
our environmental leadership program how
do we challenge our members to
um
you know take on environmental justice
activities to really um
or projects to to help those movements
and communities
um and then there's internal and
external training uh
once again training our staff
on environmental justice what does that
mean how does your job what is
what you do how does it impact people
out across the state in our communities
teaching about risk communications how
do you effectively communicate risk um
and then program specific training but
then all there's also the external
audiences
we have a lot of tools we need to do a
better job of teaching people how to
access and use the information that we
put out there um and then we need to
teach people about the permitting
process and how you do how do you get
actively involved in that how do you
read a permit how do you offer
comments on a permit um so there's all
sorts of opportunities are opportunities
for us to uh better and increase that
engagement and increase understanding
between our audiences
and uh of course uh as before mentioned
there's some great tools out there for
us to use uh as uh regulators um when
we're talking about assessing
environmental justice and and you know
what it means in these communities um so
there's ej screen which you mentioned
you know of course there's going to be
enhancements so are already a great tool
um we have our toxic release inventory
community right now and then kentucky
has something called enviro health link
which is you know a lot of our
environmental health indicators
um so there's there's lots to be done
within eec and dep and we're going to be
looking at all of our programs looking
how we can educate staff and how to you
know
really
um
get people involved um and get our
employees involved in that environmental
justice framework so um i i hope a year
out we have some really really great
things to uh talk about in this i'm
excited uh and i think this is something
that
uh can have uh great impacts for uh the
citizens of the commonwealth uh who
bear the undue burden of a lot of the uh
environmental decisions that have been
made over the years so uh with that i uh
there's my contact information should
you uh have any questions after this
please feel free to call uh contact me
so
thank you very much
thank you so much amanda we really
appreciate it
our next panelist is donovan taylor
he has completed a juris doctorate from
the university of kentucky college of
law and his management experience and
business and tax strategies
law and legal practice and community
organizing and development he currently
serves as the manager of the plan room a
non-profit business accelerator focusing
on capacity building
for minority owned contractors
subcontractors architects design firms
and suppliers
in the construction industry
donovan works with the chickasaw
neighborhood federation
rubbertown emergency act react and the
west louisville county community task
force to address area pollution concerns
thank you so much for joining us donovan
hello thank you good afternoon and
thanks for having me today uh and i
think to our previous panelists as well
uh for our institutional on planetary
impact of pollution and our
institutional activity i'm gonna bring
you home to uh
the neighborhood and neighborhood
activity um
as it relates to environmental justice
and pollution
i am a resident and native of the
chickasaw neighborhood
which is located in western louisville
which is a unique and beautiful
neighborhood
i don't know what's going on
chickasaw was established in 1922 after
the establishment of the chickasaw park
that was designated for blacks in the
city of louisville
to chickasaw is a neighborhood made of
26 different
i don't know subdivisions going on
[Music]
and our boundaries are the ohio river to
the west west broadway to the north 34th
street to the east and
on the south is miles park the
industrial park
some of the advocacy encompassment of
the chickasaw neighborhood is the vacant
and abandoned property improvements
chickasaw park improvements
and housing and quality of life
preservation
i don't know why i keep going back to
that
chickasaw is a fenced line neighborhood
and that means where a neighborhood is
located near a dangerous industrial and
commercial facilities that put residents
at a risk for daily toxic pollution
chemical releases and exposure
chickasaw neighborhood is located near
the rubbertown industrial park in
western louisville
fence line areas are disproportionately
black latino and individuals living in
poverty
fence line areas are more heavily
impacted by pollution due to low access
to healthy food and other environmental
factors
cancer risks are higher for residents
living in fence line neighborhood which
is a major concern for us in chickasaw
the rubber roadtime industrial park is
an industrial area with companies that
are producing a variety of toxic
chemicals and materials
for decades west louisville and nearby
residents have complained of the quality
of life and health problems attributed
to rubbertown i just remember is growing
up in west louisville and definitely
there was
horrible foul orders that were being
admitted from uh rubbertown that has
recently been uh addressed however the
residents are still concerned about the
pollution issues
the environmental impacts of
neighborhoods and particularly
louisville living in in nearby uh
dangerous facilities in louisville 60 of
our residents live within three miles of
dangerous facilities
when it comes to our black and uh poor
populations 92 percent of our residents
live near fence line
areas
louisville ranks at top on schools and
medical facilities located within fence
line areas
and high risk chemical and commercial
facilities threaten resident health
quality of life and even neighborhood
culture uh and those are the issues that
we have here in west louisville and in
chickasaws as it relates to rubbertown
and environmental pollution and the
quality of life in particular we have a
park that basically borders the
rubbertown industrial park and that
impacts the ability to actually
live work and play within the
neighborhood based on the impacts of the
pollution and exposure to pollution
the peninsula neighborhood activism and
advocacy
for decades resident organizations such
as rovertown emergency action and the
west jefferson county community task
force have advocated for more action and
controls and areas of air emissions and
pollution i definitely want to recognize
definitely ebony cochran who uh is the
lead at the rubbertown emergency action
group she has been a great uh benefit to
our louisville community on addressing
area pollution as well as arnita gatson
with the west jefferson county community
task force um
due to basically uh
strong community action in 2005 uh the
city of louisville ratified this
strategic toxic air reduction program
which is known as star
as an effort to reduce toxic air
contaminants in uh in the community uh
this is kind of a very innovative and
unique program that is
relevant to louisville on addressing uh
environmental pollutions in in the
community
and has been a great benefit on
improving the
some some part of our air quality
and 2018 react collaborated with eight
other u.s communities to work together
through the
environmental justice health alliance
for chemical reform to research
solutions for fence line areas
and what do you know we've just been
very active on addressing this and then
our quality of life uh and just you know
how we live and our health impacts in in
the state of louisville and when it
comes to the western louisville we have
a lower
uh
life expectancy as it relates to
individuals in other parts of the county
and so this is definitely uh an issue
that we
uh give great attention to
and one of our key
components is finding solutions and
advocating for solutions for our
environmental pollution matters
and some of the solutions that we kind
of
push forward
for the community is that required that
these industrial facilities share
information on hazards an emergency
response plans and solutions with
workers and finish line communities you
know when we worry about uh and
considering the how the impact of
quality life of these industries have on
residents we also look at to you know
like a very concerned about the workers
who also come back to the community and
and these solutions may impact their
families so definitely this effort is
very collaborative uh on addressing all
aspects of how these
industrial pollutions impact our
communities
strengthen and enforce health and safety
guidelines is a strong component for
that we advocate on the community level
prohibit new and expanded facilities
near homes and schools and as as
previously would address about reading
and understanding permits that's
something that we're working through in
our community of really getting uh
a notice of when those permits will come
out and how neighborhood groups and
individuals can respond to permits for
new facilities and expanded facilities
nearby
our communities and so that's something
that we definitely concerned about
require facilities to continuously
monitor report and reduce emissions
solutions
as well as require facilities to use as
store chemical uh and materials to adopt
safety processes whenever possible
and when it comes to the chickasaw
community we are a
small but aging community and when it
comes to addressing and being so closely
uh
located near rubber town in these
industrial and chemical plants one of
the issues like you know the possible uh
explosion or disaster that may result
at these particular plants and how the
community can respond and we definitely
are pressing that the city and state put
forth a evacuation plan
uh for the neighborhood just in case of
that particular situation happens
as we
uh
was addressed earlier about shelter in
place oftentimes when dealing with
chemical exposure one of the things they
kind of
encourage the residents to do if if
there's an issue is to shelter and place
however when you're considering west
louisville and our in the west
louisville homes which are mentioned in
many of these homes are aging and old
homes that are porous and
and so therefore actually a lot of the
residents are concerned that by just
staying in the home does that really
reduce my exposure to toxic contaminants
or maybe in the air uh
and so and so if there's another
solution that's possible of actually not
sheltering in place but actually
evacuating from the area and meaning
that many of our residents are elderly
many of our residents do not have
transportation there needs to be a
conservative plan to put in place and if
it's necessary to evacuate residents
from these defense violence communities
when there is a major disaster that may
occur
and because yes that was i think
if i can think back it was around in
2011
that one of the chemical plants at uh
rubber town actually had an explosion
that resulted in the death of two of his
workers and serious injury to another
two workers uh and the community was
very concerned on what was that
explosion impact on the community we
were told that it was the impact would
be minor and in the community of being
trusting of the information that's being
shared by these companies and these
public agencies and so just working
together with the community and engaging
with the community
to build for us to come up with better
solutions and to better address our
environmental pollution we're all
as excellent when it comes to that you
know we
in neighborhoods we're not looking at
quality air and our quality of water
but also the quality of our soil as well
in many of our urban communities and
definitely our low income communities
there's a price for more
for uh better food access but an issue
with encouraging gardening within these
communities is the
uh
whether the soil is contaminated and
and that work for the gardening in these
communities uh with this soil is a
viable option to improve their health
and overall this
chickasaw we you know our strong
community we have some great advocates
but our work is work collaborative not
only with other neighborhood groups
community groups that are addressing
this particular issue this is
um
a community-wide uh issue that requires
all of us to be involved and we
definitely as a community group we
definitely look to partner with
our educational institutions that can
provide us with the resources and the
information needed for us to have a
better stance and be able
to advocate for better solutions for our
community
the next slide just provides you with uh
some you know resources on uh activities
of
environmental industries in louisville
and particularly in the in the chickasaw
neighborhood and activities involving
react and the west jefferson county task
force
and with that
basically uh our presentation are
regarding the environmental uh justice
and impacts for the chicken neighborhood
and we definitely welcome any questions
or concerns you guys have that i can
address
thank you so much donovan for joining us
this afternoon
as our listeners have listened to our
panelists again please put your
questions in a q a
your talks have all highlighted so this
is for all of our panelists all three of
our panelists this afternoon
your talks have have all highlighted the
importance of making environmental
health disparities a top priority for
national state and local agencies
i want to first thank you for the work
that each of you are doing thank you so
much
a question
i'm sure that in many
of many of our audience would want to
join in the efforts
of addressing these disparities
what suggestions do you have for our
audience and how they can get involved
if i may jump
okay
go ahead how are you
go ahead heather
sure uh
there was a document that should be
available in the resources and that has
a lot of funding opportunities uh
announcements
um podcasts to learn about more
research that's ongoing
and then
there's also requests for information so
these are great ways to get involved and
and inform what's happening at least on
a national level and then of course
always encourage being aware of
legislation that's going through whether
it's in the national
state or even in your local community
and making making it known you know how
important
these environmental health disparities
and environmental justice
issues and initiatives are to you thanks
[Music]
uh if i may add in i would just
encourage individuals definitely uh
lay individuals to just get involved in
your neighborhood or community groups
that are addressing environmental issues
are they definitely would need your help
and that's just definitely a collective
way
to addressing it uh and definitely you
know and and creating partnerships with
other agencies and as well as you know
as far as here at uk
uh is working together
uh on community action and and
more importantly collaborating to put
forth and advance policy changes that
can have a positive and beneficial
impact on our communities
and i want to
you know echo
that you know we always appreciate
public input when it comes to
regulation and
policies um because you know uh
sometimes we don't necessarily know all
the caveats unless people make us aware
um so we we appreciate public input so
uh hopefully we'll be making that easier
for folks to um you know
identify and to
to provide
comments and and of course um getting
involved at the grassroots level in your
community and and really getting to know
your community needs is always important
um and often you know we can um
you know
help people uh connect to resources um
if we can we can work with them on
various incendiary things and um i will
say that uh yeah we have an
environmental leadership program where
we have people do voluntary projects for
environmental improvements so uh we
would love to work with some um local
grassroots folks and maybe connect them
with uh you know
entities looking to do good in their
communities too so it's it's a a match
where you know maybe we can get someone
to pay for raised beds for a community
garden uh where the soil doesn't you
know where the soil becomes a non-issue
um so i would love to to to you know um
maybe try to find ways to make that
happen too so
um i i think if we can sort of
communicate and and make those
connections uh a lot of great things can
happen so
we have another question
oh
go ahead
uh so we have another no
go ahead donovan
sorry
i'll just say we're welcome to partner
with you guys at uk here in west
louisville so definitely reach out
good deal
thank you so much and one question is
specific for heather
uh how will president biden's climate
plan impact the research priorities at
nie hs i'm not sure if you
uh well
certainly
very directly i mean when a
president has an agenda
that
you know calls for uh
you know for example the justice 40
calls for reinvestment in uh
in communities that are impacted by
climate change uh so that that is
that means that federal investment um
and we'll need to pay attention to make
sure that we're reaching that 40 level
so that's one example
um sometimes when a legislation like
this goes through
it also it means
the creation of new funds so it leads to
enhancement of opportunities like the
ones that i described um previously
and so
that it's too early at this point to
know if that's going to be the case but
that's certainly another way that
it would um make those priorities more
known in iehs
and then the other the other
the white house environmental justice
advisory committee when committees like
that form and look across the government
at opportunities they also identify gaps
in research and that is used by our
institute to
you know develop
statements about the types of work that
we feel is necessary
and those don't get advertised through
notice of intent to publish or other
means
you know that are
that come before a request for
applications might go out
thanks for that question
thank you so much heather
another question was can the study of
the effects of strip mining
and mountaintop removal mining on the
health of nearby communities now be
completed it was shelved during the last
administration
well uh what i can say is that the
united states environmental protection
agency has developed a new
mountain and
minerals division i'm not using the
right name there but i do know that
the impacts of mining is something that
is very much front and center on this
new
office within the epa
so
i i i don't know that there were
reasons uh you know within the national
institute of environmental health
sciences and i think it's true for
several other agencies doing funding a
lot of times the um the work is proposed
by the app
what the questioner described is
something that
does sound like it falls it does sound
like it falls within the niehs
mission and
you know
talking with a program officer might be
a way to find out how the work that they
are interested in doing could be funded
because i'm not aware of any
restrictions against that
just that there might not have been any
specific
announcements going out about it
thanks
thank you again heather and i want to
take the last few moments to thank our
audience and again thank our panelists
health disparities and health equity
work across our neighborhoods and how
the environment impacts
us all is a extreme top priority and so
thank you so much for all of your hard
work and i hope our panelists i hope our
audience
was moved to think about action and how
we can all work together to impact
change
thank you aaron do you have any closing
remarks
yes thank you getting my webcam back on
that was remarkable i'm i'm just amazed
great excellent work being done and
still the
that is still there that we still need
to take up the torch and do do work so
uh thank you everyone uh i want to
let everyone now take a break we have a
much
needed personal comfort break we will
begin again at 205.
uh we have an incredible lineup of
breakout sessions featuring uh cutting
edge research environmental action that
you can get involved now with water
quality and water monitoring uh enviro
atlas is here with epa
um and then please join us um following
the breakout session um
for a final wrap-up uh we look forward
to seeing you all back uh in the
breakouts thank you we'll take
five six minutes see you then